nous regrettons la campagne odieuse
balance son maire lancé par des
militants en marche
sans parler de la publication parlant de
vos ministres de la liste des maires qui
ont dû augmenter la taxe d'habitation
pour compenser jeudi vient pour
compenser vos baisses de dotations
les maires ne veulent pas de belles
déclarations ils attendent un véritable
acte de décentralisation mais au
contraire vous imposer aux collectivités
une véritable mise sous tutelle et des
économies drastiques alors que le budget
de l'elysée a encore augmenté de 2
millions d'euros cette année
monsieur le premier ministre quand allez
vous enfin faire confiance au maire et
traduire en actes les belles promesses
cool en fait à leurs proches des
élections notre gouvernement a quand
même la fâcheuse habitude de s'immiscer
dans les finances locales
concernant la taxe d'habitation françois
baroin a eu raison de rappeler hier au
président de la république que vous avez
décidé de supprimer un impôt qui ne vous
appartient pas la recentralisation est
en marche qui place les communes sous la
dépendance de l'état et déresponsabilise
les élus l'autonomie financière recule
devant l' usine à gaz la compensation de
la taxe d'habitation
les dotations s'érode car elles ne sont
pas indexés sur l'inflation
un an après les gilet jaune bien que
moins présents sont toujours dans la rue
cet anniversaire a une fois de plus été
marquées par le retour du chaos dans
certains quartiers de la capitale
les français ont eu à supporter des
images intolérable avec la destruction
d'un sol dédié à la mémoire du maréchal
juin et de nos soldats
un an après les français doit subir les
mêmes exactions perpétrées par des
vandales des groupuscules qui nie la
république et ses valeurs et ce en toute
impunité
ces violences ont choqué blessés
indignés les français il n'est pas
acceptable que manifestation après
manifestation elle puisse se répéter
que comptez vous faire pour restaurer
l'autorité de l'état monsieur le premier
ministre les fractures sociales et
territoriales qui divise la france sont
toujours là plus que jamais ce sont les
gilet jaune du tout début
cette majorité silencieuse ces classes
moyennes dont je me fais l'avocat dans
les quartiers périphériques dans les
petites villes dans le monde rural
qui disent que rien n'a vraiment bougé
le car scolaire est passé juste avant ce
sont les mots d'un riverain de mirepoix
sur tarn
peu de temps après l'effondrement du
pont sur la départementale 71 en haute
garonne
on parle de 25000 pont en mauvais état
structurelles principalement à la charge
des départements et des communes
lesquelles sont bien conscients du
danger mais pécuniairement impuissant
face au coût des travaux et à leur
complexité technique depuis près de cinq
ans en débat s'est installé en france
sur la question de l'utilisation de la
reconnaissance faciale
les nouvelles technologies nous
permettent d'avoir un outil suffisamment
performant pour garantir la préservation
des libertés individuelles tout en
assurant une plus grande sécurité
collective
qu'il s'agisse d'un enfant perdu dans la
foule de la disparition d'une personne
atteinte d'alzheimer ou de la sécurité
d'une manifestation publique
la reconnaissance faciale apporte des
résultats considérables elle est un
outil incontournable pour faciliter le
travail des forces de l'ordre
aujourd'hui épuisée par les gilet jaune
et la menace terroriste permanente qui
pèsent sur notre pays
[Musique]